Just a quick note, today's episode contains some descriptions of violence. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Priceless cultural artifacts have been plundered and sold for hundreds of years. You can find these relics in museums and in private collections. But in 2014, researchers discovered that looters had a new tool in the trade of stolen antiquities. Facebook. Secret Facebook groups, with as many as 100,000 members, are devoted to the selling and buying of cultural artifacts. Their items can go for thousands, even tens of thousands of
温馨提示，今天的节目包含一些关于暴力的描述。这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。几个世纪以来，无价的文化艺术品一直被掠夺和贩卖。你可以在博物馆和私人收藏中找到这些文物。但在2014年，研究人员发现，掠夺者在被盗文物交易中有了新工具：Facebook。一些秘密的Facebook群组拥有多达10万名成员，专门从事文化艺术品的买卖。它们的商品售价可达数千，甚至数万美元。
dollars. Producer Zena Doudar. A study of the Facebook listings found that nearly a third of the artifacts were stolen from conflict zones. International treaties, such as the 1970 UNESCO convention, criminalized the purchase and sale of lucid treasures. But even so, at the time, none of this was technically against Facebook's guidelines. And Facebook isn't the only place with a market for traffic tentiquities.
制片人泽娜·杜达尔。一项针对Facebook列表的研究发现，近三分之一的文物是从冲突地区被盗的。国际条约，如1970年的《联合国教科文组织公约》，将非法买卖文化珍宝定为犯罪。但即便如此，在当时，这些行为在技术上并不违反Facebook的准则。而且Facebook并不是唯一一个存在非法文物交易的市场。
Do a search on eBay using the vague buzzwords of the industry, words like Mesopotamian or Byzantine, and you can come up with all sorts of listings too. Here are just a few. Near Eastern Mesopotamian Terracotta plaque, $750. Circa Mesopotamian finely carved black stone bull, $623. Museum quality, original ancient plaque relief of Ishtar, the Mesopotamian goddess, $3,000. It's hard to know whether or not these specific items were looted from the Middle East, but we do know this.
在eBay上搜索一些行业模糊的关键词，比如“美索不达米亚”或“拜占庭”，你也能找到各种各样的商品列表。这里仅举几例：近东美索不达米亚赤陶浮雕，750美元；约美索不达米亚精雕黑石公牛，623美元；博物馆级，美索不达米亚女神伊什塔尔的原始古代浮雕，3000美元。很难确定这些特定物品是否是从中东掠夺的，但我们确实知道这一点。
One of the organizations responsible for the pillaged artifacts floating around the Internet is ISIS. Zaina and her team on the Curning Culture's podcast tell stories about the Middle East and North Africa. And what they reported for an episode in the latest season of their show is a comprehensive inside look at how one country struggled to retain its cultural heritage amid a brutal conflict. The Syrian war has resulted in hundreds of thousands of casualties and not to mention hundreds of billions
导致互联网上充斥着被掠夺文物的组织之一是ISIS。扎伊娜和她在《Curning Cultures》播客的团队讲述了关于中东和北非的故事。他们在最新一季节目中报道的内容，全面深入地展示了一个国家如何在残酷的冲突中努力保留其文化遗产。叙利亚战争造成了数十万人伤亡，更不用说数千亿美元的损失了。
in damages. And that battle has played out on land considered to be the cradle of civilization. I can tell you that every Syrian, literally today, lives either on top of an archaeological site, right next to Orton archaeological site, or within a stone's throw of an archaeological site. This is Amr Alaz.
而这场战斗发生在被认为是文明摇篮的土地上。我可以告诉你，今天每一个叙利亚人，实际上都生活在考古遗址之上、紧邻考古遗址，或者距离考古遗址仅一步之遥。这位是阿姆尔·阿拉兹。
He is a Syrian archaeologist. He's currently a professor of Middle Eastern history and anthropology at Choney State University in Ohio. But before moving to the states, he worked in Damascus. How did you first become interested in archaeology? Do you sort of remember the time when you began to become fascinated with it? Yes, I do because it had nothing to do with me. My mom wanted to be an archaeologist by trade. And so as a child, I would be constantly dragged around to every possible museum, archaeological, or anything,
他是一位叙利亚考古学家。他目前是俄亥俄州肖尼州立大学的中东历史与人类学教授。但在移居美国之前，他在大马士革工作。你最初是如何对考古学产生兴趣的？你还记得你开始对它着迷的时候吗？是的，我记得，因为这与我本人无关。我母亲的职业就是考古学家。所以小时候，我总是被拖着去参观每一个可能的博物馆、考古遗址，或者任何相关的地方，
to make sure I was kind of soaking it all in. Amr did soak it all in. He went on to do excavations all across Syria. So when the war started back in 2011, Amr felt like he needed to do his part, to protect the country's cultural heritage. For most of the war, foreign reporters, human rights monitors, and cultural heritage organizations had very little access inside the country.
以确保我能沉浸其中。阿姆尔确实沉浸其中。他后来在叙利亚各地进行了挖掘工作。因此，当2011年战争爆发时，阿姆尔觉得他需要尽自己的一份力量来保护国家的文化遗产。在战争的大部分时间里，外国记者、人权观察员和文化遗产组织几乎无法进入该国境内。
But Amr had local connections, so he co-founded an emergency initiative called Day After. The group was a sort of impromptu detective squad made up of archaeologists, several of them, former students and colleagues, from his teaching days in Damascus. So they would go out and try to record and document damage to the local cultural heritage sites, local museums, etc. Whatever they can visit. The group would take notes and photos of the damaged sites and report back to Amr. I had a chance to speak with one of the people he recruited for day after. A man named Adnan Al-Mahamad.
但阿姆尔有当地的人脉，所以他共同创立了一个名为“后天”（Day After）的紧急倡议。该组织是一个临时的侦探小组，由考古学家组成，其中几位是他在大马士革教书时的前学生和同事。他们会外出尝试记录和存档当地文化遗产遗址、当地博物馆等的受损情况。无论他们能访问哪里。该小组会记录受损遗址的照片并向阿姆尔汇报。我有机会采访了他为“后天”招募的人员之一，一个名叫阿德南·马哈马德的人。
We interviewed him in Arabic and had an actor voice his lines in English. He was my university professor, and he told me that artifacts are not just all things from the past, but they are part of us. Even his lectures were different. He used to stand on the table and speak about how amazing historical artifacts are and how valuable they are. Yes, yes, I did. Well, you know, there's a kind of a reason for some of this in that, you know, this is the late 90s and early 2000s and we had very little resources to teach our students with. So often I would have to try to be very creative in trying to visualize, help students visualize whatever it is I was describing. help students visualize whatever it is I was describing. And clearly, at least for Adnan, it worked. Am's lesson stuck with him all these years later.
我们用阿拉伯语采访了他，并请了一位演员用英语为他的台词配音。他是我的大学教授，他告诉我，文物不仅仅是过去的东西，它们是我们的一部分。甚至他的讲座也与众不同。他过去常站在桌子上，讲述历史文物是多么神奇，多么有价值。是的，是的，我确实这样做过。嗯，你知道，这其中是有原因的，因为那是90年代末和21世纪初，我们几乎没有资源来教学生。所以通常我必须非常有创意，试图帮助学生形象化我所描述的任何事物。显然，至少对阿德南来说，这奏效了。阿姆尔的教诲多年后依然深深影响着他。
When he joined the emergency initiative, Adnan was living in Mambige, a city in the north of Syria. At the start of the war, he said there wasn't much of a threat to the sites he was monitoring, which were mostly on the outskirts of the city. But everything changed when ISIS came. ISIS took control of Manbij in 2014. Almost overnight, Adnan's job became extremely dangerous. The day the ISIS convoy came to our area,
当他加入这个紧急倡议时，阿德南住在叙利亚北部的曼比季。战争开始时，他说他所监测的遗址并没有受到太大威胁，这些遗址大多位于城市郊区。但当ISIS到来时，一切都变了。ISIS在2014年控制了曼比季。几乎一夜之间，阿德南的工作变得极其危险。ISIS车队来到我们地区的当天，
there were about seven tanks and five or six, four by four cars with ISIS fighters inside. I watched as they arrived in my village and took someone from the village to show them around. We started to feel that even something is as simple as taking photos of artifacts was dangerous. We didn't know who we were dealing with because they were all different nationalities.
大约有七辆坦克和五六辆载有ISIS武装分子的四驱车。我看着他们到达我的村庄，并带走村里的人为他们带路。我们开始感到，即使是拍摄文物这样简单的事情也是危险的。我们不知道我们在和谁打交道，因为他们来自不同的国家。
It was scary. ISIS destroyed a lot, even did it for show at times. But they also knew that they needed to be savvy. Running at the Factor Caliphate is costly. It required a lot of equipment and manpower. So among the first things ISIS realized when they started taking over Syrian cities and towns, was that there was money to be made in looting and exporting antiquities. They see cultural heritage as a resource.
这很可怕。ISIS摧毁了很多东西，有时甚至是为了作秀。但他们也知道他们需要精明。运营一个所谓的哈里发国代价高昂。它需要大量的设备和人力。因此，ISIS在开始接管叙利亚城镇时意识到的第一件事就是，掠夺和出口文物可以赚钱。他们将文化遗产视为一种资源。
And so as a resource like any other resource, it gets put under the Wainarikas and it then becomes something to exploit. The Wiener Ricchaz was ISIS's ministry for resource management. Amri explained to us that that's where they set up their clearinghouse, which basically controlled the trafficking and sale of artifacts. ISIS would sell the stolen items at auctions in the northern city of Rokka. Everything. Everything. Misex, glass, statues, reliefs, palmarine, reliefs from Palmyra, coins, artifacts, anything, anything and everything.
因此，像任何其他资源一样，它被置于“资源管理部”之下，然后成为可以剥削的东西。“资源管理部”是ISIS的资源管理部门。阿姆尔向我们解释说，那是他们建立清算所的地方，基本上控制了文物的贩运和销售。ISIS会在北部城市拉卡的拍卖会上出售被盗物品。所有东西。所有东西。马赛克、雕像、浮雕、帕尔米拉的浮雕、硬币、文物，任何东西，任何和所有东西。
Within a year, it became a really profitable operation for ISIS. Artifacts could sell to foreign buyers for as much as $35,000 a piece. As ISIS made more and more money, the scope of the mission for Adnan's detective group grew. Now, his job went beyond surveying sites. He was also being asked to document how these antiquities were leaving Syria. Adnan would visit sites pillaged by ISIS and take pictures, smuggling the files back home on a memory card that he kept tucked away in his jacket. He was paid a couple hundred dollars a month by Amra's organization to document the
一年之内，这成了ISIS一项非常有利可图的业务。文物可以以每件高达35,000美元的价格卖给外国买家。随着ISIS赚的钱越来越多，阿德南侦探小组的任务范围也扩大了。现在，他的工作不仅限于勘测遗址。他还被要求记录这些文物是如何离开叙利亚的。阿德南会访问被ISIS掠夺的遗址并拍照，将文件存放在夹克里藏着的存储卡中带回家。阿姆尔的组织每月付给他几百美元来记录
ISIS antique trade, but the risk he was taking was massive. Sometimes I went to Mambush twice a week and beheadings were common. I always saw them beheading young people. Everybody was pale, and you could see the fear in their faces. I didn't think I would survive ISIS, so I wanted to share this information with someone who could use it in the media or in academia. Adnan would be an ISIS-controlled territory for a week or two at a time, driving his motorbike into the center of Rokka where he'd witnessed those antique auctions up close.
ISIS的古董贸易，但他所冒的风险是巨大的。有时我一周去两次曼比季，斩首是很常见的。我总是看到他们斩首年轻人。每个人脸色苍白，你可以看到他们脸上的恐惧。我不认为我能在ISIS手中幸存，所以我希望能与媒体或学术界中能利用这些信息的人分享。阿德南会在ISIS控制的领土上待上一两周，骑着摩托车进入拉卡中心，在那里他近距离目睹了那些古董拍卖。
When he had what he needed, he'd head north, wearing a black leather jacket, taking a route through ISIS checkpoints on the way out. ISIS liked the color black. I was keen to blend in as much as possible with the right length, beard and hair, because they were closely monitoring how we looked. They would take anybody who looked different out of their car and interrogate them. It was all routine questions, and I started to figure out the pattern of what happens at these checkpoints.
当他得到他需要的东西后，他会向北走，穿着黑色皮夹克，在离开的路上穿过ISIS的检查站。ISIS喜欢黑色。我尽量让自己融入其中，留着合适的胡子和头发，因为他们密切监视我们的外表。他们会把任何看起来与众不同的人从车里带出来审问。这都是例行询问，我开始摸清这些检查站发生事情的规律。
I made my sentences short and to the point. The more you say, the more chance you would make a mistake." Once he was past the checkpoints, Adnan would drive up to a town called Jaroblos, right on the border with Turkey. He'd managed to get a hold of a Turkish SIM card, and from there, Adnan could pick up enough signal to send the pictures he'd taken to his wife, who had moved to Turkey with his three children. Adnan's wife would then relay the report to Amr, who'd be waiting for it, back in the
我让我的句子简短且切中要点。你说得越多，犯错的机会就越大。”一旦过了检查站，阿德南就会开车前往土耳其边境的一个叫贾拉布鲁斯的城镇。他设法弄到了一张土耳其SIM卡，从那里，阿德南可以接收到足够的信号，将他拍摄的照片发送给已经带着他的三个孩子搬到土耳其的妻子。阿德南的妻子随后会将报告转交给在美国等待的阿姆尔。
states. And I think the worst time for me was when I knew that one of my guys was inside, basically gathering information, and I would be waiting for his transmission, waiting for, like, literally sometimes two, three weeks for him to get out again safely, and then I would know he's safe, and I could then breathe. Adnan Woodson, Amra Pictures of ISIS excavation sites or reports on a conversation he had with a local dealer. All details about how exactly the ISIS trafficking operation worked.
我想对我来说最糟糕的时候是，我知道我的一个人在里面收集信息，我会等待他的传输，有时真的要等两三周他才能再次安全出来，然后我知道他安全了，我才能松一口气。阿德南会发给阿姆尔ISIS挖掘现场的照片，或者关于他与当地经销商谈话的报告。所有关于ISIS贩运业务究竟是如何运作的细节。
But while he was undercover, there was nothing he could actually do to put an end to the trafficking. When I held artifacts, I was an agony because I knew they would leave serious order later. I would just take photos of them that the most I could do, hoping that one day they would find their way back.
但在他卧底期间，他实际上无法做任何事情来结束这种贩运。当我拿着文物时，我感到痛苦，因为我知道它们稍后会离开叙利亚。我只能给它们拍照，这是我能做的最多的事，希望有一天它们能找到回家的路。
ISIS's looting and trafficking operation is the most destructive crime against Syrian cultural heritage that the country has seen in generations. But it isn't the whole picture. Amg told us that most of the cultural heritage trafficked out of Syria in the last 10 years was done by regular people who lost their jobs and turned to trafficking because there was nothing else left. The looting starts in 2012. And I think a lot of it was what we refer to as subsistence looting.
ISIS的掠夺和贩运行动是叙利亚文化遗产几代人以来遭受的最具破坏性的犯罪。但这并不是全部。阿姆尔告诉我们，过去10年里从叙利亚贩运出去的大部分文化遗产，都是由失去工作并转向贩运的普通人完成的，因为他们别无选择。掠夺始于2012年。我认为其中很多是我们所说的“生存型掠夺”。
This is people who've lost their livelihoods. They assume in their minds that there's very treasure all over the place. Every syring knows someone whose uncle from their great grandfather's side from his second wife whilst digging in their courtyard or basement or something came across a very part of gold. So there's this kind of urban myth almost,
这是那些失去生计的人。他们心想，到处都有埋藏的宝藏。每个叙利亚人都认识某个人，他们的叔叔或曾祖父的第二任妻子在挖掘庭院或地下室时，偶然发现了一罐黄金。所以几乎有一种都市传说，
that there's this gold somewhere. So people start to dig around and look for it. And like I said, many people live near or on top of archeological sites. So they know that there's stuff in the ground. And it's not, it's not difficult for them to find it. Instead of prosecuting people for stealing or resource they were using to fund their war,
说某个地方有黄金。所以人们开始四处挖掘寻找它。正如我所说，许多人住在考古遗址附近或之上。所以他们知道地下有东西。对他们来说找到它并不困难。ISIS没有起诉那些偷窃他们用来资助战争的资源的人，
ISIS went in the other direction. They decided to manage these looted items, encouraged it even, by taking a 20% cut on all sales from private citizens. A lot of these transactions would happen after the item had made it safely across the border to Turkey. There, at auctions, dealers and buyers from all over the world joined to bid on these stolen goods. Somewhere from nearby countries in the Middle East, but others would travel from further a field. For example, there was this one well-known buyer, Amr spent ages unsuccessfully trying to track down. She was a German lady who literally regularly came down to Southern Turkey, she would set up shop
而是走向了另一个方向。他们决定管理这些被掠夺的物品，甚至通过从私人公民的所有销售中抽取20%的提成来鼓励这种行为。许多此类交易会在物品安全越过边境进入土耳其后发生。在那里，来自世界各地的经销商和买家聚集在一起竞拍这些被盗物品。有些来自中东邻国，但其他人会从更远的地方赶来。例如，有一位著名的买家，阿姆尔花了很长时间试图追踪却未果。她是一位德国女士，她经常来到土耳其南部，她会在那里开店，
there and then she would have people bring goods up through the kind of the border smuggled into where she is and then they would show her the wares and she would buy what she wants and then they would get shipped out to her. And looters were becoming savvy themselves. According to Adnan, artifacts that would fetch only tens or hundreds of dollars in Syria could be sold for thousands of dollars in secret Facebook groups.
然后她会让人们把货物通过边境走私到她所在的地方，然后他们会向她展示商品，她会买下她想要的，然后它们会被运走。掠夺者自己也变得精明起来。据阿德南说，在叙利亚只能卖几十或几百美元的文物，在秘密的Facebook群组中可以卖到数千美元。
The local swuggling networks would reach out to Adnan asking how much he thought an item could go for and to check its authenticity. Quickly, the internet was full of listings. I would guess, probably, or not legit, but the problem is there's no way to prove that. This is Mark Atowil, Vice-Din at the University College London. And as part of his research, he tracks the trade of antiquities coming from the Middle East. Maybe about five or six years ago, I remember looking at eBay, I saw I think something that looked like Kineha Form Tablet.
当地的走私网络会联系阿德南，询问他认为一件物品能卖多少钱，并检查其真实性。很快，互联网上就充满了列表。我会猜，可能不是合法的，但问题是无法证明这一点。这位是伦敦大学学院的副院长马克·阿托威尔。作为他研究的一部分，他追踪来自中东的古董贸易。大约五六年前，我记得查看eBay，我看到我认为看起来像楔形文字泥板的东西。
These things are coming out of a country where we know Kineha Form Tablet is written in a specific ancient language, usually, and it usually comes from only a few places, usually Syria, Iraq, maybe Turkey, or Iran. So it's most likely to be coming one of those countries, and seeing something like that means it's very likely to be in an illegal sale. So it should have thrown red flags.
这些东西来自一个我们知道楔形文字泥板是用特定古代语言书写的国家，通常只来自少数几个地方，通常是叙利亚、伊拉克，也许是土耳其或伊朗。所以它很可能来自这些国家之一，看到这样的东西意味着它很可能是一次非法销售。所以它应该引起警惕。
So my reaction is like, why is it so easy? For researchers like Mark, it's really difficult to track how many illegal antiques there are for sale at any given moment in Europe or the US. From the outside looking in, the market for this stuff is full of loopholes. But let me try to simplify. For an antique item to be sold legally in the US or in Europe,
所以我的反应是，为什么这么容易？对于像马克这样的研究人员来说，追踪欧洲或美国在任何特定时刻有多少非法古董在售是非常困难的。从外部看，这些东西的市场充满了漏洞。但让我试着简化一下。一件古董要在美国或欧洲合法销售，
it needs to have what they call provenance. That is essentially a kind of sales history to prove that it hasn't been taken from its country of origin after 1970. 1970 because that's when the UN brought in this rule that basically said any cultural items that leave their country of origin from now on are considered illegal loot. But anything that was their country of origin from now on are considered illegal loot. But anything that was already out of the country is fine. It's too late to try and do anything about those items. Let's say I'm a dealer, okay, and I acquired this item.
它需要有所谓的“出处”。这本质上是一种销售历史，以证明它在1970年之后没有从原籍国被带走。1970年是因为联合国在那时引入了这项规则，基本上规定从现在起离开原籍国的任何文化物品都被视为非法掠夺。但任何已经离开该国的物品都没问题。现在尝试对这些物品做任何事情都太晚了。假设我是一个经销商，我获得了这个物品。
The only way I can claim that it's legal is if I can demonstrate that this was somehow acquired prior to 1970, then anything that happens to it beyond that is legal. But if you want to talk about ethical, no, it's not legal, it was looted. This is one of those loopholes that we were talking about. Because according to Amr, it's often left up to the dealers and buyers to check provenance for themselves. The different countries have different ways of determining what is considered due diligence. And that is part of the problem. Right now, you as a buyer and a seller are supposed to do your due diligence.
我声称它合法的唯一方法是证明它是1970年之前获得的，那么在此之后发生的任何事情都是合法的。但如果你想谈论道德，不，它不合法，它是被掠夺的。这就是我们谈到的漏洞之一。因为根据阿姆尔的说法，检查出处通常留给经销商和买家自己。不同的国家有不同的方式来确定什么是“尽职调查”。这就是问题的一部分。现在，作为买家和卖家，你应该进行尽职调查。
You're supposed to make sure that the object, just as you make sure the object is authentic. Everybody does a due diligence or a lot of enthusiasm because nobody wants to buy a fake. Oh, we put a lot of effort and time into that. But when it comes to provenance, we get a little sketchy, you get a little hazy. I mean, I've seen provenance like the seller swears that they've had it in their family. What swear? What do you mean swears? Really?
你应该确保物品的真实性，就像你确保物品是真品一样。每个人都做尽职调查，或者充满热情，因为没人想买假货。哦，我们在那上面投入了大量的精力和时间。但当谈到出处时，我们变得有点草率，有点模糊。我的意思是，我见过这样的出处：卖家发誓这是他们家族传下来的。发誓？你说的发誓是什么意思？真的吗？
So you have to be really stupid to get caught. And if you look at the number of convictions from the antiquities laws that exist in the UK for instance, it's very few. You could probably hold in one hand you can count the number of convictions. So the people I know have been caught have been caught because they were ignorant of the law. And that means that the laws are not strong. It means that the burden of proof is often on people like me or others who are trying to find people who are stealing these things. And that's not the way it should be in my opinion.
所以你必须非常愚蠢才会被抓。如果你看看英国现有的古董法导致的定罪数量，非常少。你可能一只手就能数出定罪的数量。所以我认识的被抓的人是因为他们不懂法律。这意味着法律不够强大。这意味着举证责任通常落在像我这样试图寻找偷窃这些东西的人身上。在我看来，这不应该是这样的。
Our team got in touch with dozens more people selling and ticks from the Middle East on eBay. Barely any of them responded and only one was willing to talk to us in her recorded interview. Hello. Oh hi, is that Kiara? Yeah, Kiara speaking. Kiara, sorry, that's I wasn't quite sure. This is my colleague Alex speaking with a seller named Kiara based in the UK. She had a listing for an ancient Mesopotamian seal stamp on eBay for 220 British pounds, along with thousands of other items.
我们的团队联系了数十名在eBay上销售中东古董的人。几乎没有人回应，只有一个人愿意在录音采访中与我们交谈。你好。哦，嗨，是基亚拉吗？是的，基亚拉在说话。基亚拉，抱歉，我不确定。这是我的同事亚历克斯，正在与一位居住在英国的卖家基亚拉交谈。她在eBay上有一个古代美索不达米亚印章的列表，售价220英镑，还有成千上万的其他物品。
She told us that roughly 20% of the items she sells are from the Middle East, and she said that she buys most of them from job lots, that is, buying a big batch of items from an auction house or private cellar in bulk. So, like, something we've been hearing a bit about is like provenance, especially when it comes to items from the Middle East. And so when you buy something from a job lot, like does it come with provenance or... No, not always. No, I mean rarely happens, whether we have something with provenance. I mean, rarely happens, whatever we have something with provenance. Oh, it rarely happens.
她告诉我们，她销售的物品中大约20%来自中东，她说她大部分是从“批量货”中购买的，也就是说，从拍卖行或私人卖家那里批量购买一大批物品。所以，我们听到了一些关于出处的事情，特别是当涉及到来自中东的物品时。当你从批量货中买东西时，它带有出处吗……不，并不总是。不，我的意思是很少发生，无论我们有什么带有出处的东西。哦，很少发生。
Actually, we've job lots because it's just a collection of things, maybe from a collector or from a house clearance or something like this, so they don't necessarily come with something that's attached to the person or where it's coming from. Oh, interesting. So you kind of don't really have any idea about where it came from before you had it? No, no. She told us that when she buys an item that doesn't have provenance and she doesn't know much about where it came from,
实际上，我们有批量货，因为这只是一堆东西的集合，可能来自收藏家或房屋清理之类的，所以它们不一定带有与人或来源相关的东西。哦，有趣。所以你基本上不知道它在你得到它之前来自哪里？不，不。她告诉我们，当她购买一件没有出处的物品，并且她不太了解它来自哪里时，
she'll bring an expert in to take a look. But that's mostly to make sure it's not fake, not to make sure it's legal. I guess, I mean, I don't want to sound rude. I'm just asking like, how do you sort of, though, that the items that you're selling have been in the UK for long enough time that they haven't been trafficked from, let's say, Syria recently during the war? Honestly, there's truly not really a way to know, because I get all of my items from auction houses, so I mean it would be them that would have to have that responsibility of knowing
她会请专家来看一看。但这主要是为了确保它不是假货，而不是为了确保它合法。我想，我的意思是，我不想听起来很粗鲁。我只是想问，你是如何确定你销售的物品在英国已经存放了足够长的时间，以至于它们不是最近在战争期间从叙利亚走私出来的？老实说，真的没有办法知道，因为我所有的物品都是从拍卖行得到的，所以我的意思是，他们必须有责任知道
that information. I don't know that information, I don't know where the auction house got it from, so there's no way for me to know. We're not saying that Kira was selling items that were illegally trafficked into the UK, or that her items had false provenance. As Mark said, there's really no way of knowing if any one item is legal or illegal when the due diligence falls only on the seller. We reached out to eBay and live auctioneers to ask about their policies on illegal or looted
那个信息。我不知道那个信息，我不知道拍卖行是从哪里得到的，所以我没有办法知道。我们并不是说基亚拉在销售非法走私到英国的物品，或者她的物品有虚假出处。正如马克所说，当尽职调查只落在卖家身上时，真的没有办法知道任何一件物品是合法的还是非法的。我们联系了eBay和Live Auctioneers，询问他们关于非法或被掠夺
artifacts. Live Auctioneers told us that anybody selling items on their platform has to do their due diligence to make sure that what they're selling is legal. Essentially, it's up to the seller. They said they have a zero tolerance policy on listing anything that's suspected to be stolen. But when we asked if they take an active role in making sure the items sold on their website are all legal, they didn't give us an answer. eBay said, quote, the sale of illicit antiques and artifacts is prohibited on eBay, in line
文物的政策。Live Auctioneers告诉我们，任何在他们平台上销售物品的人都必须进行尽职调查，以确保他们销售的东西是合法的。本质上，这取决于卖家。他们说他们对列出任何涉嫌被盗的物品采取零容忍政策。但当我们问他们是否在确保网站上销售的物品全部合法方面发挥积极作用时，他们没有给我们答案。eBay表示，引用：“非法古董和文物的销售在eBay上是被禁止的，符合
with UK and international laws and regulations. We work closely with authorities such as UNESCO, Interpol, and the European Commission to provide a safe and secure online marketplace that prevents illegal trade while enabling the legal sale of antiquities. All sellers on eBay are required to comply with our artifact policy. We have automatic block filters that prevent listings of any items which breach our policies, and we also have teams continuously monitoring the site to identify and remove any prohibited listings. We also take strong enforcement action against sellers who violate these policies, which can include temporary bans and permanent suspensions. And as for Facebook, Amr told us that Facebook updated its community standards in June 2020
英国和国际法律法规。我们与联合国教科文组织、国际刑警组织和欧盟委员会等当局密切合作，提供一个安全可靠的在线市场，防止非法贸易，同时实现古董的合法销售。eBay上的所有卖家都必须遵守我们的文物政策。我们有自动拦截过滤器，可以防止任何违反我们政策的物品列表，我们也有团队持续监控网站，以识别和删除任何违禁列表。我们也对违反这些政策的卖家采取强有力的执法行动，这可能包括临时禁令和永久封禁。”至于Facebook，阿姆尔告诉我们，Facebook在2020年6月更新了其社区标准，
to ban the sale and exchange of cultural heritage items. But he said, the rules aren't widely enforced. Amra is still tracking dozens of buy and sell antiquities groups. For Amra and Mark, they really only see one solution to clean this industry up. Punish the people by the looted items. This is the supply and demand end.
禁止销售和交换文化遗产物品。但他表示，这些规则并未得到广泛执行。阿姆尔仍在追踪数十个古董买卖群组。对于阿姆尔和马克来说，他们真的只看到一个清理这个行业的解决方案：惩罚购买被掠夺物品的人。这就是供需的终点。
And remember, the supply side is driven by demand. So, you know, we often focus on the supply side because that's the, in some ways, the easier side to blame. Well, you're destroying your heritage, you're looting it, you're, you know, we're trying to save it, etc. How about you try and convince people not to buy legitimate entities? How about you basically clean up the trade? How about you make it illegal, so illegal, so, you know,
记住，供应方是由需求驱动的。所以，你知道，我们经常关注供应方，因为在某些方面，那是更容易指责的一方。好吧，你在破坏你的遗产，你在掠夺它，你在，你知道，我们正在努力拯救它，等等。你为什么不试着说服人们不要购买合法的实体？你为什么不基本上清理贸易？你为什么不让它非法，如此非法，以至于，你知道，
grievous that if you are caught with a traffic item from a conflict zone like Syria, that you will go to jail for 30, 40, 50 years. You know, then I guarantee you there will be no more demand, or the demand will drop to such a level that basically people won't do it anymore. You're not doing anyone a favor by buying this item. You're only, you know, pleasing yourself. The best way for this item is to stay where it came from. And as for Adnan, after spending more than a year secretly traveling in and out of ISIS-nene, بعد ذلك مرحباً من مرحباً و من المرحباً في ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل ترسل تر ترسل ترسل ترس ترسل ترسل ترسل تر cultural heritage, even with the odds stacked against him. Thankfully, it didn't come to that. It was the worst part of my life, but I'm proud of what we did.
严重到如果你被抓到持有来自叙利亚等冲突地区的贩运物品，你将被判入狱30、40、50年。你知道，那么我保证将不再有需求，或者需求将下降到人们基本上不会再这样做的程度。购买这个物品并不能帮到任何人。你只是，你知道，取悦你自己。这个物品最好的方式是留在它来的地方。至于阿德南，在秘密进出ISIS领土一年多之后，他冒着生命危险记录了叙利亚的文化遗产，即使困难重重。谢天谢地，情况没有变得那么糟。这是我一生中最糟糕的部分，但我为我们所做的事情感到自豪。
I felt like I was on a patriotic mission, like I was doing something big. 99% Invisible was produced and edited this week by Zaina Dau-Dar, Alex A.Tac and Jason Delion, fact-checking by Graham Haysha, mixed in tech production by Martin Gonzales, music by our director of sound Swan Rial. Voiceovers were performed by Abdullah Al-Asia. Special thanks to Dana Belute, Nadine Shacker, Tamara Jaburi, Amra Al-Asam, Adnan Al-Mahamed, Rosen Kamel Mahamed Amin, Mark Altowiel, Kiaro Peterson, Alice Fordham, and Salman Ahad Khan. This episode was made in collaboration with Kurning Cultures that's Kurning with Akay, you can hear their latest excellent season of that excellent show wherever you find podcasts. Up next I'll tell you about a real good podcast. Call real good. Stay tuned.
我觉得我是在执行一项爱国任务，就像我在做一件大事。《99%隐形》本周由扎伊娜·杜达尔、亚历克斯·A·塔克和杰森·德里昂制作和编辑，事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙完成，混音和技术制作由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成，音乐由我们的声音总监斯旺·里亚尔制作。配音由阿卜杜拉·阿西亚完成。特别感谢达娜·贝卢特、纳丁·沙克尔、塔玛拉·贾布里、阿姆尔·阿拉萨姆、阿德南·马哈马德、罗森·卡梅尔·马哈马德·阿明、马克·阿尔托威尔、基亚拉·彼得森、爱丽丝·福特汉姆和萨尔曼·阿哈德·汗。本集是与《Kurning Cultures》合作制作的，那是Kurning，带有一个K，你可以在任何找到播客的地方听到他们那个优秀节目的最新一季。接下来我将告诉你一个非常好的播客。叫“Real Good”。敬请期待。
Hey everyone, this is a sponsored segment about a sponsored podcast, which happens to be sponsored by a bank. So it is capitalism all the way down. However, one of the main reasons I wanted to do this interview was because the co-host of the podcast is Faith Saley. She's a contributor to CBS on the morning and a regular panelist for weight weight, don't tell me. But I first got to know her in the mid-2000s
嘿大家，这是一个关于赞助播客的赞助片段，碰巧是由一家银行赞助的。所以这完全是资本主义。然而，我想要进行这次采访的主要原因之一是因为这个播客的联合主持人是费思·萨利。她是CBS早间节目的撰稿人，也是《Wait Wait... Don't Tell Me!》的常驻小组成员。但我是在21世纪00年代中期第一次认识她的，
on her nightly public radio show Fair Game, which I had a great fondness for. Faith's current podcast is called Real Good from US Bank, and she co-hosts it with the chief diversity officer of US Bank, Greg Cunningham, who refers to himself as an accidental banker. And when I spoke with them both about their show,
在她每晚的公共广播节目《Fair Game》中，我对那个节目非常喜爱。费思目前的播客叫《Real Good from US Bank》，她与美国银行的首席多元化官格雷格·坎宁安共同主持，格雷格自称是一名“偶然的银行家”。当我与他们两人谈论他们的节目时，
you could tell that Greg was a man on a mission. For me at least, the purpose of the podcast was to sort of break down these barriers to trust. I mean, particularly in communities of color, there's a well-earned history of this trust. I mean, the banking industry has earned it, right? And so so much of it was about bringing these people, these stories, these tangible examples
你可以看出格雷格是一个有使命感的人。至少对我来说，播客的目的是为了打破这些信任障碍。我的意思是，特别是在有色人种社区，这种不信任有着深厚的历史。我的意思是，银行业已经赢得了这种不信任，对吧？所以很大程度上是关于把这些人、这些故事、这些切实的例子带进来，
of how we were putting our money where our mouth was, that we weren't just making these big pronouncements like other companies were like making in the wake of George Floyd's murder, but we were actually doing the work. And we were actually being really transparent about the outcomes that were happening as a result of the investment we were making. And it wasn't just about a bunch of activity and that we wanted to be really transparent about the progress and let the public hold us accountable to making progress. And it was all of that. It was all of, you know, us really being truthful about our why. Like it wasn't just about the what of the work we were doing. It was why we were
展示我们是如何言出必行的，我们不仅仅像其他公司在乔治·弗洛伊德被谋杀后那样发表宏大的声明，而是我们实际上在做这项工作。而且我们实际上对我们投资所产生的结果非常透明。这不仅仅是关于一堆活动，我们希望对进展非常透明，并让公众监督我们取得进展。就是所有这些。就是我们真的对我们的“为什么”非常诚实。就像这不仅仅是关于我们所做工作的“什么”。而是为什么我们
doing it and why it was important and who we were doing it with. So that's the perspective of someone who works for the bank who's from that community, who's trying to get the word out. But Faith, you are not coming from that world, you're writer, a storyteller, what do you get out of these conversations and what do you hope other people will get out of it?
在做它，为什么它很重要，以及我们和谁一起做它。所以这就是一个为银行工作、来自那个社区、试图传播信息的人的视角。但是费思，你不是来自那个世界，你是一位作家，一位讲故事的人，你从这些对话中得到了什么，你希望其他人能从中得到什么？
You know, as a storyteller and a writer, I had this amazing gift of primarily being a listener and a learner, right? My mind has been blown over the three seasons of talking with Greg and the people we've gotten a chance to talk to together, Greg. Well, this is what I've heard, Greg, you can tell me if you agree with this.
你知道，作为一名讲故事的人和作家，我拥有这种惊人的天赋，主要是作为一个倾听者和学习者，对吧？在与格雷格以及我们有机会一起交谈的人交谈的三季中，我的思想受到了极大的冲击，格雷格。嗯，这就是我听到的，格雷格，你可以告诉我你是否同意这一点。
That over and over these black leaders, these black change makers are expressing that not only are they representing themselves, but they are representing their people, people of color. And a lot of them feel like they say that they only get this one chance that the ability to fail or stumble is frankly a privilege that has not been open to everybody. And over and over, I also hear that there is an absolute commitment to giving back to community in a way that I haven't heard from from other types of folks, right? I'm right, you can hear me being very careful with my language because I am saying here's what I've learned
一次又一次，这些黑人领袖、这些黑人变革者表达说，他们不仅代表自己，而且代表他们的人民，有色人种。他们中的许多人觉得他们说他们只有这一次机会，失败或跌倒的能力坦率地说是一种并没有向所有人开放的特权。而且一次又一次，我也听到有一种绝对的承诺，以一种我没有从其他类型的人那里听到的方式回馈社区，对吧？我是对的，你可以听到我在语言上非常小心，因为我在这里说的是我从
from interviewing black people, and it feels a little uncomfortable. I don't want you to, but I don't want you to ever feel like you need to be careful on choosing your words, because I think that's the beauty of what the show is about. Me too. And because it is about those moments, faith of discomfort.
采访黑人中学到的东西，这感觉有点不舒服。我不希望你，但我永远不希望你觉得你需要小心选择你的词语，因为我认为这就是节目美丽的所在。我也是。因为正是关于那些时刻，费思，不舒服的时刻。
And you and I have talked about this so many times. Like, none of us learn from a place of comfort. You don't grow from a place of comfort. You can only grow from that discomfort. But what's important about it is we, over the course of these three seasons, we establish such an incredible relationship that's grounded in trust, as I said before. Like, we give each other that grace. Let's talk a little bit about who you talked to on the show. The episode you sent me
你和我已经谈过很多次了。就像，我们没有人从舒适的地方学习。你不会从舒适的地方成长。你只能从那种不舒服中成长。但重要的是，在这三季的过程中，我们建立了如此令人难以置信的关系，正如我之前所说，这种关系建立在信任的基础上。就像，我们互相给予那种宽容。让我们谈谈你在节目中采访的人。你发给我的那一集
was about Houston White, who is an entrepreneur from Minneapolis, who has this whole vision for a mixed-use residential commercial district in his neighborhood on the north side. What is it about him and his story and the story of the other interviewees on the show that compels you? I want to talk to people that I think have vision and have a story that is inspiring. It's like somebody whose story is so human that there's something in it that everybody can relate to. You mentioned Houston light, and I think about what's so inspiring about Houston in addition to the stories,
是关于休斯顿·怀特的，他是来自明尼阿波利斯的企业家，他对他在北区社区的混合用途住宅商业区有整个愿景。关于他、他的故事以及节目中其他受访者的故事，有什么吸引你的地方？我想和我认为有远见、有鼓舞人心的故事的人交谈。就像某人的故事非常人性化，以至于每个人都能从中找到共鸣。你提到了休斯顿·怀特，我想到了休斯顿除了故事之外有什么如此鼓舞人心的地方，
this notion of how he wants to bring culture and capacity together, to say true to the authenticity of these neighborhoods and the culture of the neighborhoods. It's unbelievable what he's done with his block in North Minneapolis and it's going to continue to build this community that I think is something that the rest of the country's been on to replicate.
这种他想要将文化和能力结合起来的观念，以保持这些社区的真实性和社区文化的真实性。他在北明尼阿波利斯街区所做的事情令人难以置信，并将继续建立这个社区，我认为这是全国其他地方一直在试图复制的东西。
I think that's the stuff that is really fascinating to me as people who just have incredibly human stories that we can all relate to. Faith, was there something specific from Houston's story that resonated with you? Yeah. from Houston's story that resonated with you. Yeah, when Houston was talking about how he began being a business man to quote his favorite Jay-Z lyric, as an 11 year old who would cut hair. And when he started explaining that hair and the line of the hair and what was status and that status was currency and self-respect, and then self-empowerment.
我认为这对我来说非常迷人，因为人们只是有令人难以置信的人性故事，我们都能产生共鸣。费思，休斯顿的故事中有什么具体的东西引起了你的共鸣吗？是的。休斯顿的故事中引起了你的共鸣。是的，当休斯顿谈到他如何开始成为一名商人时，引用他最喜欢的Jay-Z歌词，作为一个11岁剪头发的孩子。当他开始解释头发和头发的线条，什么是地位，地位就是货币和自尊，然后是自我赋权。
And Houston talks about how barbershops are this place where old black American men could go and feel equal, feel respected. And then Houston talks about how he very purposely puts the board room in the middle of the barber shop. We actually have a clip of this because I really like how he describes this. Here's Houston White on real good talking about his board room table in the middle of his barber shop. Typically, we hide things like this. You know, this is where you, you have to go in a back room to have a board meeting.
休斯顿谈到理发店是老黑人美国男人可以去并感到平等、感到受尊重的地方。然后休斯顿谈到他如何非常有目的地把董事会放在理发店中间。我们实际上有一个关于这个的片段，因为我真的很喜欢他描述这个的方式。这是休斯顿·怀特在《Real Good》上谈论他理发店中间的董事会桌子。通常，我们隐藏这样的东西。你知道，这是你必须去后台开董事会的地方。
But I mean, there was a screen that said, welcome US Bank. And we did a whole presentation, right? When everything was happening in the barbershop, so people could see it, almost like an artistic installation of what really happens at the highest level of business. But we're just going to bring it right and normalize it. And folks are walking in like, what's going on? And then my mom walked in.
但我的意思是，有一个屏幕写着“欢迎美国银行”。我们做了一个完整的演示，对吧？当所有事情都在理发店发生时，人们可以看到它，就像一个关于商业最高层真正发生什么的艺术装置。但我们只是要把它带过来并使之正常化。人们走进来问，发生了什么事？然后我妈妈走了进来。
Like, yeah, yeah, funny thing. I'm a true story. I'm a true story. And funny part, he, and so he looks at his mom, faith, and says, mama, I made it. I did. Oh.
就像，是的，是的，有趣的事情。我是一个真实的故事。我是一个真实的故事。有趣的部分是，他看着他的妈妈，费思，说，妈妈，我成功了。我做到了。哦。
It was such a surreal moment. My favorite moment of the whole episode with Houston is when he says to you, Greg, thank you for seeing me. Thank you for seeing me and all that's contained in being seen, right? literal investment, but also, but also the investment of support and access and mentorship and a shared vision of the community he can create. Thank you for seeing me. And advocacy, right? I mean, so much of, you know, those of us who have positions in these large corporations,
那是一个如此超现实的时刻。我和休斯顿那一集最喜欢的时刻是当他对你说，格雷格，谢谢你看到我。谢谢你看到我，以及被看到所包含的一切，对吧？字面上的投资，但也包括支持、机会、指导和我们可以创造的社区的共同愿景。谢谢你看到我。还有倡导，对吧？我的意思是，我们这些在大公司担任职位的人，
it's all about what are you doing with your position? What are you doing with the positions of power that you have? And I think that's the challenge for all of us who had professional success and sitting in these halls of power and these corporations. It's what are you doing with it? And for me, if I wasn't supporting people like Houston, those deals wouldn't get done.
关键在于你如何利用自己的职位？你如何利用你所拥有的权力地位？我认为这对我们所有在职业上取得成功并身处权力殿堂和企业中的人来说都是一个挑战。你到底在用它做什么？对我来说，如果我不支持像休斯顿这样的人，那些交易就不会达成。
If I want advocating for it and sort of pushing people. The only response here is yes. The question is how do we get to yes? And that means we're going to have to do some things differently within our organization. That's when we talk about systems change. It's not just external systems change. It's also inside these walls of power and corporations as well. To hear more stories from Faith and Greg about black and brown entrepreneurship and equity,
如果我没有为之倡导并推动人们。这里唯一的回答就是“是”。问题是我们如何达成“是”？这意味着我们必须在组织内部做一些不同的事情。这就是我们谈论系统变革的时候。这不仅仅是外部系统的变革，也是这些权力殿堂和企业内部的变革。想听更多关于费思和格雷格讲述黑人和棕色人种创业与公平的故事，
subscribe to the Real Good podcast. 99% invisible is executive producer is Delaney Hall. Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The Rosa team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Barupay, Christopher Johnson, Lashma Dawn, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are part of the Stitcher & Serious XM podcast family, now headcored six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown Oakland, California You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook
请订阅“Real Good”播客。《99% Invisible》的执行制片人是德莱尼·霍尔。库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。该团队成员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·勒、乔·罗森伯格、克里斯·巴鲁佩、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉什玛·道恩、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我，罗曼·马斯。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰上城区，向北六个街区，在潘多拉大厦。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。
You can Twitter me at Roman Mars and the show at 99pi orc wrong Instagram and read it too You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99pi at 99pi dot org love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99mpi.org. Serious exam. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99pi，也可以在Instagram和Reddit上关注。你可以在99pi.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目以及99pi的每一集往期节目。SiriusXM。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。